Scott can you take us through a
realistic scenario of a screenwriter
pitching an idea to an executive where
does it begin
usually it takes a good amount of
schmoozing to get the meeting in the
first place so there is a lot of you
know sort of getting your foot in the
door
professionally when the meeting actually
is secured it usually starts at log
lines usually an executive on the other
side of the room is looking for specific
types of programs they'll want they'll
be kind of overly specific in terms of
like they want mysteries about XYZ they
want romances about ABC and they'll sort
of like walk you through a very
clear-cut expectations of what they're
looking for in a project and they're
usually looking for a list of log lines
or very very short synopses like 100 200
words and that's usually done by email
honestly when you do secure the meeting
and in today's world it's almost usually
Zoom or some kind of a teleconference
you just sort of walk through those
ideas a bit but it's really much more
about sussing out who you are what you
bring to the table how many variations
of the same thing you can sort of
deliver upon in the hopes of maybe not
just doing a one-time deal but actually
building more of a relationship ship and
a partnership
so that you can sort of get repeat
business with a client
so you've already been vetted before
you're doing a zoom meeting okay it's
not just a blind pitch where someone
wants to do their sort of HomeTown Story
and they don't really know the person
they've kind of gone through the proper
channels yeah I mean look it's it's to
get that meeting the process to sort of
reach that
you know it's if you find a company
that's willing to to look at content
from new people that's pretty critical
um so that can be you can reach out to
people via LinkedIn you can reach out to
them you know online you can you can do
enough research and find their contact
details or at least some general you
know info at XYZ company kind of uh uh
email someplace and those will actually
get reviewed and read
um I'm not saying there's a real high
turnover in that but it's a uh it's it's
people do evaluate that and if there is
something there that sort of matches a
general sort of feel of what the company
looks for if it sort of matches the
brand and what that company delivers to
the market
um yeah you usually will have somebody
reach out and it's it's not just one
script they're looking for people who
sort of can deliver
um a high output somebody who's coming
to the table not just with like one
screenplay and that's what they have
they want somebody who has three
screenplays or five screenplays not that
they'd read them all but they just sort
of want to know that this is a writer
who's who can deliver who is kind of a
writing machine so to speak and can just
keep getting new versions as I said sort
of the same thing of the same kind of
genre out there
what's the bare minimum experience
someone has to have to pitch in
Hollywood
you need to be able to show that you've
sort of done the work in a sense the
Catch-22 when starting out for anybody
starting out in a career is you have
zero professional experience but the
people on the other side of a table want
to see that you've done something
they'll look you up on IMDb they'll look
you up your general sort of online
presence to get a sense of Who You Are
and if you're trying to break into
writing or something creative it's
actually quite challenging because if
you don't have those credits in place
sort of how do you prove that what's fun
about today which is very different than
20 years ago 30 years ago is that
anybody can kind of create their own
website and can sort of present
themselves very professionally through
any number of social media Outlets so
you can sort of create your own
personalized brand VIA website or
something else and even if you have no
professional credits you can sort of
showcase some of the um styles that you
work within some of the writing samples
that you have and sort of present
yourself that way uh I think having that
sort of presence is a great start and
then I would say you sort of need a I
call it like a critical mass of of
um materials to be able to show and that
would be like if you want to be a
screenwriter my personal advice is you
need at least two scripts if not three
that would be the ideal and you need
about five to ten like ready to go
fleshed out log line ideas and a log
line being you know 75 words to 100
words Concepts that do show that
beginning middle end concept of a movie
and I think that with that you're sort
of coming to the table
um with a good amount of volume and a
professional background that's enough
sort of to secure that meeting and sort
of get that process going so if you're
going to markets if you're going and
just sort of cold emailing people so to
speak
um you know not everyone's going to
immediately turn and respond right away
but you know you might get you know 15
that do and if they do they can quickly
sort of dive in there and see that no
this person sort of has potential let's
see what they can deliver on let's see
what their log lines are like let's see
what a synopsis looks like maybe they'd
be willing to write on spec and writing
on spec in this case would mean hey
we're doing 20 movies a year and the
network will only buy from us if there's
a script and we don't want to put out X
number of dollars to get a script that
may never get green lit so what if we
worked with a writer on spec we can get
the screenplay for you know a lower
amount up front and then if the green
light takes place the rider gets the
remainder of the money and it's a great
opportunity for for new writers
especially to sort of get their foot in
the door really show a track record with
a Distribution Company or production
company multiple there's you know they
don't have to be exclusive and uh really
start you know kick starting their
career
okay and so what if they've they've done
their homework on the production company
they know that they're going to be
pitching a similar genre they have five
let's say scripts ready to go they have
other ideas but the thing that's going
to get them is their IMDb only shows
like short films but they've actually
done rewrites but it's not reflected in
their IMDb because we hear that a lot in
comments well this person hasn't done
anything but they actually have it just
isn't reflected in their IMDb how do
they how do they kind of handle that
work around that
I mean
on my side of the industry I work very
much on the business side and
um
there's like a fraction of the titles
I've actually worked on in a creative
capacity a development capacity
um a distribution capacity uh I don't
have my name on those films
um and that's how most of us are on our
side and distribution and development
you know we don't we don't get credits
all the time and so uh you showcase it
in other ways basically you know it's
it's much more about the deals I've
closed and sort of the contacts that I
have our business is really built on
relationships
um so I think that if you're a newer
writer or somebody who does have
experience it's about cultivating the
relationships uh my my real view it's
it's like such an old saying but it's
like it's it's really this industry is
built on relationships it's about who
you know that's not enough to just
that's enough to sort of sometimes get a
door open but that's not necessarily
going to land the deal or get your first
opportunity going and that's all on your
own shoulders and that's actually it's a
little bit scary in a sense but in truth
like you have the most control over that
because you can come into the room with
the right kinds of scripts with the
right sorts of ideas with the right
personal
um presentation in the sense of being a
professional and wanting to work and
willing to put in the work to get it
done